all right we're back at matt khan i'm
here with carol swain who did a
phenomenal video for prageru called the
inconvenient truth of the democratic
party
you also have a new book coming out
what's the title of the book it's
already out it's black eye for america
how critical race theory is burning down
the house and it was written for the
american people and it explains what
critical race theory is where it came
from how it manifests itself
and had runs counter to christianity our
civil rights laws our constitution and
best of all it has two chapters on how
to fight back it has a glossary because
you know they keep changing the terms
right the words don't mean what they
meant yesterday well the book was
current uh two months ago in the terms
but we know that every day they come up
with new stuff right and racism doesn't
mean what racism has always meant and
being a white supremacist doesn't mean
what that meant you know five years ago
your white supremacist
i know that you really aren't no offense
no and i'm a black white supremacist so
what can we say my good friend larry
elder is also a black white supremacist
i know an awful lot of black my friend
david webb's a black white supremacist
there's a lot of them there's a lot of
it it's like one did you ever think that
was going to happen to you well the
southern poverty i'm always ahead of
myself
i'm ahead of everyone else so in 2009
the southern poverty law center because
i
had criticized them for um
for um
the um their
slide into
hate yeah yeah i call them the southern
poverty hate center basically well yeah
and so i sort of said that and um
mission creep i accused him of having
mission creep
and maybe three months later i pick up
my
newspaper in nashville and there's a
front page article that i'm a i'm an
apologist for white supremacy this was
in 2009 most people didn't know who i
was
and so
all over you know black media people
were discussing me
and there was nothing i could do about
it until james duranto at the wall
street journal did a 2000 word article
defending me in defense of carol's main
but i was the first black american to be
called a
white supremacist sympathizer i believe
you are in good company because they've
put me on one of their lists too so
we're both on well you wear it as a
badge of honor yeah it is a bad device
being a black white supremacist i wear
that proudly because that means that i
recognize the civil rights of all people
including white people who are also
protected by civil rights laws all right
so let's uh let's do some 101 stuff here
because you're an academic at heart
uh let's do some basic definitions what
is critical race theory my audience
knows it but give me something that we
can clip put on twitter and every time
somebody says you guys don't know what
critical race theory is we can put it
out there i would say that it is a white
supremacist a theory that divides
americans between oppressed and
oppressors
and the people that put it out there it
is white supremacy because it says that
white people control the faith of every
other human being like i have no agency
as a black person because you the white
person has power over me only you can
liberate me i can't even be racist only
white people can be racist because only
white people have the obligation to be
anti-racist so it's a racist theory from
the political lab that comes from the
rich tradition of racism from the
democrats and you showed up to this
interview on time which i know is part
of the theory right if you show up on
time and you work hard you're a white
supremacist oh i am white yeah
you were early actually so i don't know
what to make of this um
are you shocked i mean since you've been
ahead of this for a while are you
shocked how pervasive it's become in
society right now or did you sort of see
that this was gonna i knew that uh that
um
the cultural marxism
was uh becoming a danger in 2012
and this was after you know
this was doing president obama's second
term and so he was the one that really
energized it and for many americans many
parents you know after george floyd's
death and after the riots and
corporations started pouring money into
diversity equity inclusion and crt
that's when they became aware of what
was being taught
in the classroom so they are late comers
this has been going on for a long time
and my greatest regret is during the
time i was teaching at princeton
i was not paying enough attention to
what was taking place around me i was
congressional scholars very much focused
on congress and what was taking place on
the national scene but i wasn't paying
attention to all those seminars and
speakers about crt and
post-modernism not realizing how it was
going to impact our lives today and i
wish i had paid more attention but after
president obama
was elected and started his second term
that's when i started to really dig into
marxism cultural marxism in particular
yeah
and crt is one of many different marxist
theories because
you know you have a
critical queer theory critical feminist
theory
critical gender theory and it's all
impacting our society but we're focused
on crt because it's taking all the air
out of this room i almost hate to ask
you this question because i've asked it
to a lot of my my black conservative
friends but like just on a personal note
when you come to these conservative
conferences and they say all the bad
stuff about you not the conservatives i
mean you know all the the lefties say oh
you sell out and all the nonsense just
on a personal note
how do you deal with that nonsense
because i think a lot of people in their
own personal lives are worried about
i'll tell you this when i was at
princeton i was a democrat
and i wrote a book called black faces
black interest representation of african
americans in congress and it argued that
political party was more important than
the race of the representatives as long
as blacks tell the views they did that
best be represented by democrats
consequently it didn't make sense to
draw majority black districts because
majority black districts elected more
republicans that got me labeled as a
conservative i never got invited to the
clinton white house and they started
calling me a sellout back then and back
then i had not had my christian
conversion experience
i thought i was a good democrat they
totally rejected me and i found that
progressive faculty members including a
well-known conservative who's at harvard
now that was at princeton who saw
herself as the champion of black people
she actually
worked against my appointment because
she said i was not the right kind of
black person for princeton
and um it was like because i had come
you know from poverty i was a high
school dropout one of 12. married at 16
ged
community college before i went on to
get four other
college and university degrees
so
i had a non-traditional background my
story embodies the american dream it's
about possibilities and they did not
like that yeah and i was a democrat i
was rejected
were you shocked were you shocked yes i
was
i was rejected by the progressives but
embraced by the conservatives
and it turns out they're not a bunch of
crazy racists huh
have you encountered any racism here
have they been shouting you down or well
let me tell you something that uh
my um
my undergraduate degree the professor
who became you know my mentor and my
friend and all of this stuff like that
he was a republican but when i started
to college the black students who always
meet other black students to warn them
about who the racist professors are they
told me he was a racist professor but i
had this weird personality like if
someone tells me not to do something
i'll do it yeah and so i signed up for
that professor's class or the one that
was supposed to be racist and i met a
b-plus in the first class i've took
probably three or four other classes
with him i always made an a and he was
the first person to tell me you know
you're really a republican
back then that was like dirty words
nobody i was saying nobody wants to hear
that at the beginning of the red pill
process because everyone gets that
moment ah you know you're kind of a
conservative or something but it was uh
2009 before i officially became a
republican but i became a started
becoming conservative after my christian
conversion experience in 2000 and i was
in my 40s and i can tell people you know
wherever you are on life's journey
i was on a journey you know searching
trying to figure out my place in the
world because i'm never really fit until
now yeah
here we are
i know isn't it cool it it it is and you
know i feel the same way but i have so
many years on you like i
fully accept myself and so like i don't
get attacked all the time like the left
may attack me but i'm accustomed to that
i'm telling you that i feel the love
when i go into black communities i feel
the love from black youth i am not a
person that's being harassed or rejected
by black people i may be uh rejected by
black elites but they've always treated
me that way so i mean i don't care about
them i care about the american people
and i don't identify as
black i don't identify as white either i
identify as christian
identifies conservative
republican is further down and black is
further down because god created one
race the human race i believe that we
all brothers and sisters you know
whether you're jewish or you're a
christian or a muslim or whatever you
are i believe there's one divinely human
race
in the image of god and so you know like
i'm going to live my life i'm going to
say whatever i want to say i don't
censor myself and i encourage everyone
else not to do this i've never ended an
interview with a high five but i want to
give you a high five all right and we're
good can we i'm gonna demand that you
sit down for a proper interview we're
gonna get you in studio for a full hour
long because we just we barely did
anything here all right carol thank you
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell